i love daft punk i just like wow the
scent the noise sounds nice
like i like the noise you know what i
mean is that weird is that weird
yes it is weird am i weird it is very
weird yeah i know i think you just
basically described
music in in in the most like bare bones
your parents like watch trash taste and
yes like they comment on every little
thing you do now
my mum told me that like to stop putting
my hand near my face and for the past
like five episodes i've
tried to avoid putting my hands anywhere
near my mouth
yeah my mom's like oh you wore shorts
this episode the entire world
knows you're wearing shorts this episode
by the way why are you wearing shorts
shorts boys
apparently on camera they showed it when
i sat on this side she was like enhanced
enhanced my mum gave me [ __ ] whenever i
was saying that british food is awful
i was neglected growing up because i was
beans and toast often it's true though
but anyway welcome to this episode of
trash taste and
i'm your boy connor i forgot what i was
supposed to say with
joey your boy i'm your boy because i
couldn't figure the rest of the words
i'm your boy i'm with the boy
that's it that's the other boy and
together we are the boys the boys
that was had to be one of the best
intros yeah i just you know when you
like
you're auto piloting the intro and then
you just realize halfway through that
you're auto piloting the intro
you're like taking it over and you're
like oh wait i should have just ordered
because like being on a podcast
um normally if i'm having a normal
conversation sometimes and i know like
i know sometimes i know what when i
start a sentence i know how i'm going to
end the sentence but when you're on a
podcast
you always have to finish the sentence
even if you kind of realize halfway
through that you're not yeah
i'm just i'm just like okay i'm gonna
have to say something because i've been
silent
for the past two minutes but i don't
know how to start it or how to end it
where this is going
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right you're
right
so gentlemen i thought considering i i
believe we all watched
japan sinks recently a nice little
quinky dink there
we all watched it separately i didn't
know you guys were watching it we all
didn't we didn't make an effort to all
watch it we were all just like
oh we all just watched we all just
turned on netflix and it's like oh
okay it came out recently of the time of
recording but so by the time you're
seeing this microphone
like three or four days ago yeah
something like that yeah yeah for us um
but so to explain what uh japan is
uh since we're gonna be doing uh some
kind of discussion around it
it's the new masaki yuasa anime that was
released on netflix
and it's basically about a giant
earthquake that happens in japan
um and after that earthquake happened
japan starts sinking i guess
yeah so for people living in japan it is
anxiety
the anime essentially dude okay first of
all before we get into talking it the
in the very first episode they play the
actual the sound
they play this sound that you're hearing
here
did we like i don't know if i changed my
phone yeah i checked my phone
i was like where's my phone and i turned
that [ __ ] down because i was like [ __ ]
what if my neighbor's here
they start freaking out like they're
gonna think there's an actual earthquake
the elderly you know below me yeah [ __ ]
that made me [ __ ]
that gave me so much anxiety the first
episode of them portraying
the earthquake happening i was really
impressed that
how realistic it felt you know what i
mean because
i probably would have would have reacted
the exact same way it was all the
characters right
you know when you hear that earthquake
like notification now
and then you just kind of block it out
you're like oh whatever it's probably
yeah it's probably a small earthquake
because
once you've been through about 10
earthquakes in japan which you will yeah
which which you will
you just you just you hear this
notification and it's just like another
day of the
unfortunately though every time at least
i have heard that notification it's
never been the case of ah
whatever it's probably just a small
earthquake because it always happens at
like
five in the morning yeah and it's the
thing i wake up to
imagine just having you're just having a
nice sleep
wherever you are and it's like 4 30 in
the morning and then suddenly you
hear this absolutely anxiety-reducing
alarm because
you just hear the siren but they don't
say like if it's strong
yeah if it's weak it just says he just
says brace yourself yeah
just basically brace yourself hold on to
your butt
it might be strong and it's i already
hate waking up to the sound of an alarm
but when it's an alarm where it's like
oh i might die
yeah then it's it's the worst
i i had i was enjoying the first episode
so much because again there was this you
know as you said
it's a really realistic portrayal yeah
but the moment i hear that sound i just
i don't know i don't get anxiety often
but i went like the caveman spongebob
they do it like three times yeah yeah i
would stop doing this
please use a like parody noise like
something like
could you imagine though like especially
in that first episode you know when that
second
big wave yeah yeah do you think
something like that
is going to happen well didn't they it's
like a lot of again i should have done
research for this episode but i swear
there's been a few scientific
predictions that are like there's going
to be a mega quake within like 30 or 50
years
something like that i mean there has to
be right because yeah i mean we the
[ __ ] planet's like no planets the the
country's all pangaead away right that
doesn't just happen
right yeah yeah there has to be stuff
that's moving constantly so yeah and
there's like
something big is gonna happen inevitably
whether it's in our lifetime or like a
children's lifetime or [ __ ] great
great great grandchildren's lifetime
it's going to happen
somewhere like a mega quake like a mega
quake you know it's it's an interesting
idea to explore that there's probably
going to be
some massive kind of event that's going
to happen
sometime in there is there like i don't
know about i'm sure thailand has
earthquakes right
not really i mean i think japan is
literally on the fault line yeah the
whole
country is on your fault like okay do
you guys remember your very first
earthquake experience yeah yeah yeah
that was because okay we're from the uk
yeah it is literally the safest place on
earth yeah yeah i was about to say you
guys don't get earthquakes right yeah no
no we're like we are like the furthest
away from like any fault line of like
any country
like we like natural disasters in the uk
is like non-existent it's like running
out of tea
england is so [ __ ] safe you have to
try really hard
to get yourself killed in england by
nature
because australia we don't have
earthquakes at all or anything
but everything else would just be we
have you know bushfires and stuff like
that and of course our
animals are just out for blood but you
guys don't even have dangerous animals
right no we don't right that's why i'm
convinced there's so many like famous
british explorers because they must have
been so
[ __ ] bored of the uk like oh it's
another [ __ ] squirrel
talking to americans and canadians who
go camping and they have to worry about
bears and stuff like that and
i remember going camping in england and
i'm just like oh yeah like i guess we
have to worry about deers
i guess deers can be dangerous and i
feel like the biggest worry in the uk is
how much alcohol do i bring
like how much alcohol is the right
amount of alcohol how much alcohol and
toilet paper do i bring
yeah that's always the worry it's like i
gotta carry two liters of water
ten liters of alcohol so we gotta try
and bounce this out
now yeah i don't know i remember my very
first earthquake experience wasn't in
japan it was actually
in america during ax oh yeah
it's 28 well not last year now yeah oh
no it is last yeah last
year yeah last year's ax so 2019 ax and
i remember
i remember the first one yeah that was
like my very first really
yeah wow so yeah to explain when we were
at ax last year we went through a
magnitude is it seven it was like
six or seven but it was far away so it
wasn't awful but it was still
i mean we were it still is the strongest
earthquake i've been
in even after moving japan yeah and i
remember i was on like the
64. and it's it's
it was like such a humbling experience
because at first
i didn't know what was going on because
i i i i remember standing up and i felt
a bit dizzy
and i was like what the [ __ ] going on
am i just like really fatigued am i
hungover what's going on
so i go i go up to the window right just
imagine you're going up to the window on
the 64th floor of a skyscraper
and then you look down and then you see
the [ __ ] building just shift yeah
like that and it was just like this
like i immediately i've never felt
vertical
so fast and i immediately just pinned
myself against the wall
just being like [ __ ] [ __ ] this is an
earthquake
i'm surprised you had the balls to go
towards the window
because i didn't know it was an
earthquake i just thought i was just
dizzy
or drunk or something i mean the first
one because there was like
three that weekend yeah no that was two
two two in the
it was in the same day yeah so the first
one i was in the elevator while it was
happening
and the elevator was shaking a lot more
than i thought it should have been
shaking
and i'm pretty sure there's a japanese
woman in there who was from one of the
stanzas yeah
and she looked [ __ ] terrified oh yeah
and i was like
we're nearly near the bottom i'm sure
it'll be fine
we're like 10 floors i'm sure we got
this but then the second one was i was
with you yeah yeah that was so
funny do you want to tell that story you
used to tell you okay okay
so the second earthquake that happened i
think it was only maybe a couple of
hours after wasn't it yeah yeah i think
it was like rushed to your hotel room
because i was busy
that's right that was like that night
yeah it was it was you me aki and our
friend nabi
and we were just chilling in our hotel
room we were just talking about what we
were going to do that night because i
think
we're going to a party we're going to go
to a party and so we were just chilling
before the party started
and you know the second earthquake comes
through and it was i think it was
stronger than the first one wasn't it i
think so something like that but either
way very strong like at least magnitude
six
from what i remember i think it was 7.1
though i think that was the seven wasn't
it yeah
and uh and of course it was an
earthquake i'm used to it uh
obviously everybody else wasn't yeah so
we quickly ran out and we were at the
very very top of the thing was like the
68th or 69th yeah or something of that
of that hotel
and and even amidst all the panic
connor and my friend navi they were
eating uh i was thinking chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a
like chick-fil-a nuggets and connor and
nabi just kind of looked at each other
and went
well if i'm gonna die might as well
finish off these nuggets
like everyone was panicking i remember
there was literally that like
stereotypical american family there's
one dude one like white guy with like
three
daughters like get get down to the floor
get down to the bottom floor dardis i'm
gonna i'm gonna direct you and i'm there
with like my nuggets walking past him
i
if i'm gonna die at least i'm gonna die
with nugs in my hands
rushing down the stairs we got like 20
floors down and i was like i'm not you
know what
i i don't want to do any more physical
exercises i think
i think i've done enough so yeah i did a
move which is probably not a pro gamer
move i was like you know what
the shaking stopped like two minutes ago
i'ma get the elevator
there is 50 more floors and i would
rather die literally than get these
stairs
and i went to the elevator but the weird
configuration of this hotel
you had to go back to the top yeah
yeah so that means then i was like all
right well the elevators are still
working they should have been stopped
they were still working so i was like
okay so i go back from the 50th floor
which i just walked down
from the 70th i walked all the way down
and i was like okay i'm going to go back
up to the 70th floor
i go to get the elevator to go all the
way down and they're blocking it off
yeah like you can't go until it's safe
and i'm like
[ __ ] me well our other friend was just
like [ __ ] i'm gonna walk
all the way down all the way down he's
just waiting at the bottom and he calls
me he's like
where are you are you guys alive yeah
because i convinced them i'm like listen
guys you guys can keep walking i'm
getting the elevator and then they were
like
okay yeah i was like oh great we're back
i guess we
ran down 24's for no reason it was so
scary though because i remember
like i was a little i wasn't worried
because you know the doors were closing
and opening on their own i thought
that's okay i can deal with that
what i didn't like anticipate was when i
looked out the building i could
literally see the
building opposite us we were going like
this yeah yeah like parallaxing yeah
yeah and i was like
oh that's not right like
buildings shouldn't do that because i
remember it was it was like to me
it was a really humbling experience just
at that moment
i was like my life is not in my own
hands yeah like if this building
collapses
there is literally nothing i can do
because you know when you feel like
something bad happens you feel like you
have some
some kind of control like you might see
a car coming and you you think you know
maybe i can jump out of the way of this
there was like if the building was just
like logically i knew this building was
designed
to withstand earthquakes but in my heart
i was like okay at this moment i'm just
putting my faith in the engineers and
the builders
that they've done their job [ __ ]
correctly because if they haven't i'm
dead
and there's literally nothing i can do
about it
and i i i guess that was like a first
for me you know i i i'd never been in
that kind of situation where i had just
my my life was in the was in the hands
of like completely something some other
external to be fair i've experienced a
lot of earthquakes in my life but
being on the 69th 17th floor was
definitely a first for me yeah
you know i've been on you know apart
i've been in apartment buildings that
are like
10 20 floors high and that was still
scary because again the whole thing is
shaking i
have to keep telling myself it's good
that it's shaking it's good that it's
shaking
um but my first i think the scariest
earthquake experience i had was uh it
was in japan obviously
um and it was up north where my grandma
lives right um and it was where
you know the giant earthquake of 2011
hit essentially so that is
that place is like a hot spot yeah
massive earthquakes um
and uh and i was there i was in some
kind of
like uh dvd rental place
like a really old dvd rental place near
there with my sister and
suddenly i think it was like an
magnitude seven and a half or something
like that
really really big it was so big in fact
that all of the dvds and books on the
shelves just
flew out oh wow and me and i had to like
grab my sister's hand and just [ __ ]
get the
hell out of there wow and but we
couldn't go all the way out because the
shop assistant was like don't go out
into the street because if
the street if a [ __ ] falls then you're
dead yeah so we had to kind of
stand in the door frame or the shop and
just kind of
wait for it to settle down and yeah that
was definitely a lot scarier because
being on i thought being on a building
was scary being on the ground floor
like on the street in something that big
is really scary because people running
out and i thought that's kind of dumb
because the building's
really safe yeah yeah yeah running out
you don't know what kid like
exactly if a traffic light or a you know
a street light
falls on you then you know i think it's
that sense of control
you know that you think you have even
though statistically you you are
actually safer in the building yeah
the buildings are designed at least the
newer ones i think like i mean that was
a
really big hotel and it's they're mainly
designed for like 13 magnitude
earthquakes
yeah like they're pretty [ __ ] sturdy
speaking of sense of control though
uh the characters in japan sinks have
none
oh my god can we go back to that yeah no
no are we gonna we're gonna small things
it's gonna be the first spoiler warning
that we need to do
we've had a spoiler warning before okay
there'll be a spoiler warning on screen
we're gonna
spoil things it's only 10 episodes it's
on netflix don't watch it go watch it
it's great uh if you don't care about
being spoiled feel free to watch um
i hate the main girl so much i could not
stand her
i i didn't mind her at first but then
when she started to get a bit windy
later on can i can i okay to get my to
get my opinions
out of the way um what do you guys think
of the
series overall i'm glad that we finally
have some good propaganda for youtubers
i'm glad that
we need more youtube propaganda
youtubers are good
more op youtubers dude i'm so glad i was
like wow he's a youtuber and he's not an
[ __ ] this is something no no no no
because
this is amazing okay so there's a
character in uh
in in japan sings that is just a
youtuber
and he's a youtuber who's a [ __ ]
superhuman because he can do everything
he's magical
we're just not gonna explain it
the way that he enters in that [ __ ]
fan propelled
like yeah i know and he's just like yeah
this is mine i bought it with my youtube
ad ram
and it's like what videos are you
uploading you're really telling me
you're going to film a video of okinawa
sinking and that shit's going to be
monetized come on
millions of people die they're monetized
no way
can we just appreciate that the
character is basically felix pewdiepie
he just like whiteheads
it's like the idealized vision of
pewdiepie like this is
this is his final form right just rocks
we see pewdiepie i wouldn't be surprised
if he changes his profile picture to
that character next because it was ryo
from yeah it's real it's real
it looks like rio yeah but i guess when
i saw that and as you said it was
probably one of the first times that a
youtuber has been kind of viewed in
a lot more positive life fashion it
really it goes to show me that i think
massachusetts is a fan of youtube yeah
it just it just disappointed me that in
his final scene he didn't
he didn't send them off by going and
don't forget to like and subscribe
yeah very unrealistic there was never a
poll
there was not one sponsorship right now
in the whole thing come on
no rage shadow i want to imagine
he comes in the trunk flying away like
freezing half to death in the
stratosphere and he's like
spots my right shoulder
out of 10 was it or was it good or bad
what are you guys okay
i'm not going to say that it was a 10.
i'm going to give it like a solid seven
i thought it was like a four or five
really you didn't like it nah
i didn't like it either okay here's his
i couldn't stop watching it
yeah but i i didn't so many things i
hated
right okay here's the thing this the way
this is like a proper mixed bag for me
yeah same the way i would describe it is
that it's a
four out of ten series with uh some 10
out of 10 scenes
okay it was really weird because some
scenes were [ __ ] amazing it was like
yeah
peak yourself first two episodes
absolute bangers no exactly
right and like some of the scenes in
like the last two episodes absolutely
bangers as well like like the scene in
the scenes with the youtuber and like
some some of the death scenes
oh the guy's running yeah yeah yeah i
think i don't i don't know what you
asker has about that was amazing
emotional running scenes yeah but it's
and the father's death
completely caught me off guard and i was
like oh cool the one character i liked
yeah is dead too i literally thought
like
wow this like after i finished episode
two i thought like this could be a 10
out of 10 if they keep up with like how
good this is
and then and then we went into the
culture and they got to the cult and i
was like
oh no this is awful this is actually
awful like
the the cult arc for me was so
bittersweet because as a massive fan of
us's stuff i'm like oh this is so young
there's the scene what the [ __ ] was the
co-op
what the [ __ ] was it okay i gotta hit
the 360 no
[Laughter]
i was just watching it dead serious and
the kid just gets [ __ ] destroyed by
this rock
she just
it was so perfect comedic timing it was
just he turns around it's like
oh casa yeah it was like it was
like slapstick
because i remember i was like properly i
was properly invested in this
same my first two episodes i probably
probably invested and then like
some things just fell off like as as
as the series went on right because like
i remember their father dying
and it was he'd he died in a really
horrific [ __ ] way
yeah and then nobody really just
acknowledged that they had like
just cuts doesn't it yeah they had like
one conversation it's like oh you you're
forgetting dad
and then they just like next scene like
happy-go-lucky [ __ ] shopping
in in a supermarket i'm just like like
if if that was real
i wouldn't be able to say anything for
like the next five days yeah yeah yeah
yeah
even think about it and yet for some
reason every other character that dies
after
that they have like a full-on emotional
scene but yeah it drags out like crazy
right
yeah yeah it it something just felt off
about the characters i
don't know what it was about how they
were written but
it just didn't like sometimes they acted
the way i would imagine
people would act and sometimes they just
acted in a completely random way
yeah and then the cult arc happened and
i was like
okay okay now now now we've gone from
something feels off to
this is just stupid so much needed
explaining about that like whole thing
where were they getting all of this food
from where were they getting all of the
weed
there's so much weed like it's just
fields of weed
and like in japan like you're just gonna
grow fuel completely
they never explained the fact that like
the the the grounds where the cult stood
wasn't affected by the tilting there was
just so much there was so much stuff
when it got to the cold arc where i was
like this is too much too many holes for
me to just like be like this is okay
because at the end of it all i think the
only
reason i was trying to figure out okay
what was the point of this called arc
like like what were they trying to build
to
and i think the only thing that came out
of this cult arc was
just the fact that they got that morse
code talking professor out of there
right
but why was he there none of this was
explained
it was just a slapstick comedy like like
i remember watching the coal talk and
you know that point when you're like
really invested in the show and then
yeah
you go from being invested to just
laughing at how bad it's become
yeah that was the cold talk for me and i
couldn't get invested back into the show
after that
yeah it hurt too much after the cult
happened and the fact that they just
were like
okay if the old man is addicted to
morphine i'm fine with that
but they didn't even build up to that at
all they could have showed some kind of
you know right right like they could
have maybe shown him taking some pills
the fact that the old man shot that kid
at the end of episode
four yeah yeah and then they were like
and then then he was like oh i'm sorry
you know whatever i didn't mean to shoot
you let me fix your game boy
dude you just [ __ ] shot my kid yeah
with the intent to kill it
like if he didn't have his [ __ ] ds
like he he would be dead
and you're just gonna let him know he's
actually the last ps vita ever
at the end of episode four when the kid
got shot i was like oh thank god he's
dead
my god that kid was [ __ ] annoying
okay did you you what did you actually
sub the dubbed
i watched both i watched sorry i like i
literally i was like i watched the dub
something fell off i watched the sub and
for the first time my [ __ ] life i
i could not stand like the voice
lighting in the scene it was
really like i get it that they're
supposed to be like native in both
but then i feel like they should have
got people who are native and both it's
terrible
because when they whenever he said let's
go it's just like that's not
yeah it sounds like yeah
well they could have even have just
gotten someone with a similar voice type
who speaks english you know what i mean
what is it what is it about
you also did this in devilman crybaby as
well where ryo's
english was just stop doing this stop
doing this
and yet somehow they can't get i made
this joke on twitter but
i think it was the second to last
episode when they're in russia yeah and
they got those like three
nurses who could speak perfect russian
and yet they can't get a
single english voice actually yeah it
was like what why
how is it so hard because in the dump
how do they deal with the the
do uh bilingualness they they didn't
really the boy just always spoke english
so that's that's why they mentioned it
at all that he could speak
i mean like they kind of do i wanted
them to just be like i want to meet my
older son
[Laughter]
it's just like a reverse is it like a
huge plot point because then later on
when the
like the barrage comes with the japanese
only
oh the japanese kkk which the the whole
you know the the dynamics of that boat
just the engineering stands of it were
all
horrific both yeah you couldn't handle
waves like waves could just come off it
literally burst into claims
no reason like oh my god sorry i just
got yeah it was the i've got
engineering the more the more we're
discussing this the more i'm regretting
giving it a seven
like the emotions it gave me were ten
yeah yeah yeah yeah
like like let's let's let's not forget
that they also added a
woman who could speak to the dead that
was just what's up
never explained
there was two points i burst out
laughing one one was the kid dying and
the second one was like the [ __ ]
mexican standoff where she just brings a
[ __ ] samurai
is this kill bill is this a kill bill
that was such a quentin tarantino scene
where it's like
this there's a guy with a bag full of
gold bars with a gun
and she just rocks off with a samurai
sword and the guy just walks up the
stairs like
uh and i'm just like what am i watching
i thought i was watching like a disaster
movie
and it's turned into [ __ ] kill bill
it was just i couldn't stop taking sick
i couldn't stop laughing at that point
what did you guys think of the last
episode
it was a really [ __ ] hated the last
step yeah the last episode just kind of
dragged out for a little bit too
last episode was uh remember when the
olympics was meant to happen right now
well this is this is awkward don't
forget the paralympics too
just gotta make sure i mean i'm sure it
would have hit harder because
the olympics would be happening right
now yeah if this was released right now
i'd be like oh that's that's a pro gamer
move there you are so i see
i see you but but now that the olympics
isn't happening it was just one giant ad
for the olympics oh no it wasn't
like i didn't want to say that but like
it definitely like felt a little
a little ad-like like look how amazing
the olympics are and it's like
yeah we know yeah we know how good the
olympics are or
how good it should have been because i i
didn't like maybe i
was i wasn't paying attention to this
but i saw a lot of people commenting
saying that the show was like very
political
at times and i was thinking like i don't
know if it was that political people are
trying to put that on it like i didn't
get that did you get that vibe no not
really
yeah i mean maybe they were talking
about the rap scene
uh maybe which i liked i like the
rapture i like the rap scene well that
was a this
this doesn't this is a really random
scene but i'm all for it it was a good
scene it was random though i was like i
don't know what this is
but we can keep doing it but it's such a
yuasa move where you know he was just
like okay i really want to tell
people how much i love japan but how
much japan
sucks but not make us super political
yeah freestyle rap baby let's do it
yeah so originally was the rap in
japanese in the japanese stuff yeah yeah
yeah because like
i didn't notice because i at that point
i was just purely watching the english
dub
and it was all in english and it it was
really really done well so i
i didn't know if it was a case where
they just like had that one specific
scene in english
um but not like i really enjoyed that i
really enjoyed the last two episodes
not the last two episodes like episode
nine and the one before that yeah those
are two really strong episodes yeah
they had like like i said i wasn't
invested in the characters at that point
which is really weird because there were
some scenes that like i felt something
even though i had
zero investment in the story and the
characters but just because of like
the sheer brilliance of some some of the
ways these scenes were directed i was
like
yeah man i'm i'm i'm feeling something
even though i really shouldn't be right
now yeah
um did the mom have to die like i was
thinking like i was like did she have to
enter life here for this because they
kind of went like i don't know if they
probably went further but it was like
one minute on the boat oop it's out of
fuel
i think it was implied though that
because her like device hadn't run out
of battery life she was literally going
to die but then she had like a solar
panel
no no because like that thing hadn't
become busted oh it had
oh so the implication was that she was
going to die i didn't pick that up
because
i thought is she just killing herself
for like the lulls here
she's just drowning for like i mean this
is like i have to fill in my one death
per episode yeah
at this point it was just they were just
killing characters that's what it felt
like it felt like they were like every
character was going to die now and we
were just trying to sit through it like
i didn't feel like it was
needed yeah and the one character that
should have died a million years ago
which is the crippled doctor
survived how somehow
i don't know how no like yeah that's
that was my biggest problem with it
because it wasn't the fact that people
were dying it was the fact that
you just knew that someone was gonna die
like it was it was just okay
here's the scene where this person's
gonna die you know there's no
tension or anything you're just okay
well they're gonna die
and they're dead and everyone's moving
on now and it's sad and you should be
sad
and japan's sinking yeah so like but
youtube are good
no it's really weird though because i
was having this conversation with joey
earlier though i think we could we can
end the spoiler discussion now no more
spoilers
unless unless there's anything else you
guys want to discuss about the series
specifically
why of all pro games did he become a
league of legends pro
and totally unrealistic
and he's not a little [ __ ] i mean he
kind of was there actually maybe he was
yeah maybe he was a league player
no but uh yeah it was it was really
weird because even though
it was like i would give like a four or
five out of 10 at the end of the day
um i still ended up having like a good
time watching your netflix i don't know
i don't know i don't know why
i couldn't look away yeah it was great
like i don't know why where
where it's i i find it so easy to watch
anime on netflix as opposed to watching
anime on like any other platform
i've been saying this since early 2018
ever since devil may cry baby and other
well it was around the time when netflix
just started to get their hands on a lot
of anime ips
that with at least with stuff that comes
out on netflix you know castlevania did
it really well
i think i think the reason why netflix
can kill it so hard with anime is
because
they know that most anime viewers
including probably all three of us
we'd like to watch shows just in one big
chunk oh my god castlevania is so
[ __ ] yeah because
[ __ ] so amazing right and i think
what it is is that because
whenever they release something new they
just go we know you can't wait
an entire week so we're just going to
give you the whole thing all in one go
and it's perfect because netflix is
designed
to binge it's just to be binged right
yeah it also feels like there's no
seasonal pressure as well
no if there's just one big show that
drops yeah don't watch it right it's
it's it's not it's not it's not under
any kind of like scheduling no it's not
because i've had plenty of shows where i
want to binge them and i wait
like they're on crunchyroll or
funimation or whatever platform and i'm
like okay i'm going to wait for this is
for this to be over and then i'm going
to binge it and then it's over
and then i don't binge it and i just
don't watch yourself because by the time
it ends there's another
whole new batch of shows that you're
interested in now
you never have time to go back to it
yeah and then i've watched so many like
mediocre anime on netflix i have no idea
why but like
you can download it it's super easy i
remember watching
i think be the beginning as well i was
like severely disappointed in how that
turned out
like i watched it i watched it all in
one night
and i still there are still many shows
on every other platform that i just
still have not watched and i'm just like
are on my plan to watch
this so yeah i don't know what it is
about watching shows on netflix so it
just makes it so it's just painless like
it's so easy to watch like they make it
way too easy for you to enjoy it the way
you want to enjoy it yeah right
they just they just know how the the
viewing habits of
people of our demographic and the app
works so well on your phone so it's so
easy to just chuck that [ __ ] on the
chromecast
yeah yeah yeah like you know saves where
you are it's so good we're not sponsored
by netflix
but if they want to hit if they want to
hit us up
okay how would you feel about the uh
skip opening button though
i love the skip opening button i i like
the option
like i like i like having the option
yeah but like it's but i don't like how
the default is
that yeah i don't like how the default
is skipping because wait they don't
they don't skip it straight away yeah
they do the first time you watch it
you you don't have the option well you
do have the opportunity to skip it but
it plays it for you automatically
but every time after that then yeah i
think they just assume that
you're going to skip it which sucked
because when i was watching b stars on
netflix
i was like i don't want to skip this i
mean yeah we're [ __ ] opening yeah b
stars you watch but yeah
you don't have to do it so i had to keep
going to touch it joey it's there in
case you don't want it
it's not like touch me touch me cherry
touch
speaking of masaki you also though like
how much us
stuff have you guys watched in the past
um
i've watched most of this stuff except
for probably
kaiba um is that his
yeah that's yeah devil man is here oh
he's a king as well i still
yeah it's it's fun it's funny that i
still haven't watched a
ken yeah even though i've watched japan
sings which i feel like is going to be
worse than a
kid and he's against been out for a
while he's a kid he's done ping pong the
animation oh i love being
done kaiba he's done mind game mind game
is one of my favorites kick hearts as
well which was the kickstarter one
right um he's done a lot of uh indie
films
as well he does yeah your way i haven't
seen i haven't seen i still haven't seen
that
yeah i really need to watch that it's
about the it's like uh
girlfriend boyfriend dies they both love
the ocean and their boyfriend
reincarnates as a wave
yeah that's the only way to describe it
right that's the easiest way to describe
it it's like a hentai yeah
boyfriend resurrects as a water beast
yeah essentially no because i think my
favorite yuasa work will
like is at the moment ping pong the
animation oh my god yeah
ping pong's fantastic that hit me on
like a really [ __ ] deep level
different yeah i really want to stop
saying that
every time we're on it's like oh this
this show just hits this dude
and different i i guess because it's so
like relatable in some way like you've
probably been good at something without
trying and you've also probably
not been i mean we had a lot of comments
last week that was
yeah connor's chess story is basically
ping pong the animation just with chess
yeah yeah you know what i mean but the
way it just portrays
it because to me it's not a sports anime
you know
to me ping pong the animation is a life
anime that happens to follow characters
around
one single one single sport because it's
it's such a good metaphor for life in
general when it when it comes to the
discussion of talent you know versus
hard work
and just basically how crushingly
depressing
life can be sometimes life isn't fair
yeah life life is not fair and
no one's entitled to anything
unfortunately i mean that's the whole
reason why i
[ __ ] loved marsh comes in like elaine
because that's essentially the exact
same
thing that yeah that's not what you want
to see it's it is not a show about shogi
like you'll get into shogi
after watching it but much like ping
pong the animation it's just a story
about how
it doesn't matter how good you are at
something you're still going to be
depressed as [ __ ]
yeah i've been putting it off i'm like i
don't want to be depressed
it gets pretty easy i know it does i
do you think japan syncs is his worst
work that you've seen so far then
like the three i've seen yeah it's
probably i mean i haven't seen
everything masakiosa has to offer yeah
i've seen a lot but
i i'd probably say it's yeah it's
probably his weakness yeah i think
definitely for me it was his weakest and
it literally just removed the cult yeah
that's good
so many problems will be solved if he
just had yeah i i
would say no not every problem would be
solved but a lot of it
it would be like a lot better because i
still had problems with how the
characters were written
and how the story played out but
removing
removing the middle arc would have made
it like an easy
seven to eight out of ten yeah um
because there was still like i said
there were still some amazing scenes and
there was some planning amazing and it
was like peak you are certain if i was
actually invested
i i would think that this show had some
pretty amazing moments in it
um because i feel like just you got
bogged down by its story so much
yeah um whereas his other works i feel
it was it was like a nice combination
between this yuasa style of directing
because
he has a i don't know some of his scenes
the way the way he
the way he portrays and directs
especially like the emotional scenes
they just
they they can hit really hard and i
don't know what he does she's so close
shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
i definitely think that you also
regardless of how strange it is that the
way that he portrays
you know character designs and just
movement in general just animation
just animating okay i'm one of those
anime viewers who does not care who the
director is or any of that stuff
i just watch the show and that's how i
watch your anime i do that
with everything so i mean i could tell
it was from the same guy who did
devilman within like 10 seconds
yeah yeah yeah yeah just tell yeah
that's how i do because yuasa's
films and series have this really weird
thing where sometimes
you look at a character design obviously
wow that looks
pretty cool and then the next scene it
looks like it's written by
like the intern you know it changes i
think there was like a few frames in it
where it was like
characters talking and it was like bruh
like paint
you can take a screenshot of that and
just be a pokemon
i will say out of like all his works i
feel like japan syncs was his most
like normal looking work in terms of
visual style
no no no no you like you compare ping
pong the animation and then you go to
devilman crybaby and then japan
sinks i i would i would say he's
progressively gotten
in terms of his big series yeah more
like
more like normal ping pong is one ugly
luck in show but
in a great way in a great way like he
had a very unique art style and
some of the scenes were like they had a
very unique animation style and some
i would still say sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't work so well
um but it was definitely a very yuasa
style i mean
at least you know it's him yeah yeah how
many [ __ ]
of those generic isekai shows are you
like i are these all animated by the
same [ __ ] people they all look the
same
i can't tell you ask any soccer guitar
and they'll probably know it's like
this was directed i don't care like it's
like
i see an easy guy protagonist now and
it's literally a carbon copy of kirito
yeah i i remember doing like a copy and
paste of
seven different like isikai protagonists
and they all looked
exactly the same it was all that
generally probably because they're all
a1
it's the exact same art style the exact
same animation all the time and it's
like it's such a breath of fresh air you
can get anything different
oh no that's what i love about masakusa
because he's just so
weird that it's just instantly
recognizable especially
you know japan sinks as you were saying
even though it looks the most normal
probably to the general anime viewing
audience they would look at those
characters and be like oh that looks
[ __ ] weird
but then you go back to massachusetts
catalog you watch something like kyber
yeah like that thing that doesn't even
look like anime yeah yeah that thing
looks like uh
you know some kind of like disney demo
that it was locked away in the disney
vault for a while
yeah the art style's weird i can't get
into it i'm like you'll know
you'll appreciate it it's an acquired
time once you acquire that taste
taste acquired
i was going to say i completely forgot
about the one shot and you're also
getting one show when we're talking
muscle like yo sir um to tommy galaxy
oh no tommy galaxy was [ __ ] a man
like you watched
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] amazing it's
monogatari but on crap
it is like this this this will test your
reading ability
to the max if the monologue is so fast
that
japanese people struggle to keep up with
it
what the [ __ ] do you just go back the
i've never heard of monologue and just
talking scenes
that go by so god damn quickly yeah it
is it is monogatari on crack essentially
it's
it's basically like if you take one of
guitar but try to speed run the dialogue
and that's that's an episode of the
tatami galaxy but it's [ __ ] great
yeah that and that's on top of the
[ __ ] crazy mosaic you was a visual
yeah where it's just like i don't know
if this is like a dreamscape or if it's
just
weird yeah yeah but it's great it's
fantastic uh one thing i wanted
one thing that we kind of like glossed
over in terms of japan things that i
want to talk about though
is the music i thought the music was
fantastic i thought it was phenomenal
and i i i think that definitely some of
it made some it it was what helped make
some of the scenes
that main track i think it played most
of the first episode
when the main character was running back
to a family that kind of slow piano
i think song i love that track because
it's really
positive sounding and yet putting it
next to
the absolutely devastating visuals yeah
it's just becomes
such a creepy song where it's like oh
everything and everyone is dead because
like i think
well like what sold me on the first two
episodes was just seeing seeing some of
these like horrific scenes horrific
landscapes and hearing this
beautiful piano track that just gave
this like juxtaposition
that just like it was really unnerving
but beautiful at the same time like i
the way i described it to sydney was it
felt like i was watching some
something that was horrifically
beautiful yeah and i
that that was it was like a beautiful
destruction yeah yeah exactly
and i don't know who the composer was it
sounded very similar to
devman crybaby's soundtrack in some
scenes as well i don't know if it's the
same composer
did i probably should have done my
research before talking about japan
sings on his podcast i mean i'm sure
it was done by science sarah who did you
know devil may cry baby so i assume it's
the same
guy but i i don't know i'm sure someone
in the comments can tell us about that
but
yeah i love that piano track because i
don't know it
i'm not gonna lie the first time i heard
it i it kind of reminded me of the
minecraft soundtrack
a little bit i was like if this played
during minecraft i would not be
phased in any way i thought [ __ ] damn
it
can someone in the subreddit take that
piece of music and
put it over minecraft let's play it and
see if you can spot it
it's like god this was such horrific
beauty this the juxtaposition was
amazing
joey minecraft it sounds like minecraft
that's what i was like oh minecraft i
don't know if i'm just dumb but i cannot
remember any of the music you really
can't no i watched it all in one sitting
though
yeah we all did yeah did you watch one
sitting yeah yeah yeah yeah oh okay i
don't remember [ __ ] we just have a
bigger brain
clearly i think i was preoccupied how do
they get a tank
okay a question to you then what kind of
osts do you remember what sticks out for
you then
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh anything where like the music is like
a huge selling point i guess
what what what do you mean ah i mean i
don't want to be that guy but
like the one that sticks out immediately
are you remember cowboy bebop like
yeah that's right like but i wouldn't
listen to jazz on its own i'm like so
i'm like this just sounds like a mess
i mean i've i've come to understand that
when it comes to music you're a little
bit brain dead
yeah yeah because you don't you don't
really listen to because you know god
and i can have a conversation of oh this
band is the intellectual
awesome and yet i i i remember i asked
connor once i was like who's your
favorite band and he was just like i
don't really have one i'm like
i like no i like daddy punk you know why
because it's just noise most of the time
like i i hate like i never listen to
lyrics like i i'll have like listened to
like
i think i listened to like popped up
kicks like a thousand times or someone
was like it's about school shooting and
i actually listened to it yeah
like oh yeah i guess it is i don't know
if i'm just like
i don't know what's wrong with me you
want monkey brain
it's that monkey brain coming back man i
have like half a monkey brain half giant
brain depending on like what i can do
you know a single composer
kevin penkin aside from kevin franken
because he's our [ __ ] mate
he's like he said he's not composing our
minds
he's just a man do you know what he
composed other than made an abyss
uh yeah other than tal of god shield
hero yeah
okay okay it's pretty the boy's not
completely brain dude that's good
i guess because i focus more on voice
acting than anything and that's like
taking up all the noise input i can take
right like i don't really give a [ __ ]
about the music
to me the music is just does the music
not enhance your viewing experience
the music to me is so [ __ ] important
no no not really like if if
if uh if there's a shitty series with a
good soundtrack
i'm still going to remember that i
absolutely agree to this day
like i will never forget guilty crown
despite how
[ __ ] guilty crown turns into
that like will invoke an emotion in me
from like if they've been a soundtrack
but
as far as it goes it's like but have you
never listened to a song on a soundtrack
and just gotten popped no
not at all like uh maybe at the gym like
i'll put anime soundtrack to get hyped
too and maybe a you know
okay but but say for example premiere
yeah you [ __ ] love that music right
it was a great movie do you remember the
soundtrack
no how what the hell
how is it that the most in your face
composer that has ever existed in anime
connor's like if you were like if you
were like no impression if you like like
describe a song to me from from that i'd
be like i have no [ __ ] idea
no no no you you watch pro you watch
attack on titan yeah you uh what else
what yeah
about the one that goes i i never wanted
from attack on titan i don't know what
to kill the kill you remember killing
yeah kill the kill either that's okay
that's yeah i remember like individual
songs but if you ask me like describe
them or what i like about them i'd be
like they're more like crayon colors too
like for all i care you could put like
[ __ ] kevin macleod music whatever
kevin mccloud mcleod's
there's like there's definitely been
some generic sounding soundtracks that
but they're normally like for generic
shows right but yeah i don't know a
soundtrack can
easily sell me a series i wish i could
give a [ __ ] i don't know
[Music]
i it's with music as well i love daft
punk i i just like wow the
the noise sounds nice like i like the
noise you know what i mean
is that weird is that weird yes it is it
is very weird
yeah i know i think you just basically
described music
in in in the most like i think bare
bones monkey breaks
a bunch of noises i think i actually am
like a caveman when it comes to music
i'm like oh
the beeps and the boobs are very
pleasing music goes boom
yeah i mean that's a huge reason
when it comes to soundtracks that's a
huge reason why i love
anything made by uh key studios right
because yeah
jun is a [ __ ] amazing composer and
he's like
just subtle piano tracks or any of the
openings and endings just
it builds on the scene so [ __ ] nicely
and it adds like a whole
like totally like at least to me i don't
know
maybe i'm the only one but i could just
listen to say
any track from clannad or air yeah or
little busters yeah and
it could be a specific song that can
evoke a specific scene and i could
easily shut it
just from listening to it like his work
is basically if you want to hit
the emotional g-spot yeah you know what
i mean like you you hear it and you're
like
oh oh [ __ ] no it feels like how does a
single piano put
this much emotion behind it i have no
[ __ ] idea you're like the mike was
asking me more he's just standing there
right now
this conversation
i don't know you are the first person to
ever describe darf punk is
noise it's like i'm just saying present
noise
is the way i like it you mean music
interstellar
three whatever it's called what is it in
stella five five five five five five
that's great yeah i love that that's
great i love that
has has the track never evoked emotions
from you though
like have you ever listened to actual
evo emotion okay what's your favorite
dark punk track
oh that's hard i really like face to
face okay why is it your favorite track
oh my god is it because it evokes an
emotion you've seen his face he's never
thought about this thing
before i don't know why this is my
favorite song no i
i like all the sampling in it i think
it's like crazy how creative they are
with sampling
right so you're looking at them so is
there okay think about the one
daft punk song it doesn't have to be
dark just think about the one song that
has evoked like
any kind of emotion in you what song
would that be and what emotion would
that be
yeah i i don't think there is i don't
think there is a song that evokes
emotions in me
is that mad is that what does that mean
what does that mean about me as a person
i'm talking to a [ __ ] brick wall here
i'm like
it's like trying to explain to you know
peppa the android what music is
it's just like it does not compute it's
like i feel like i'm alien right now
what is
emotion what is culture
what is this i don't know i guess like
for me i maybe that's why like i focus
i i'm i feel like i'm really uh strong
in being able to
uh really break down voice acting in
shows and really like
get into it but i think that's because
i'm completely [ __ ] ignorant but what
like brings
emotions to you the story and the
characters
and the performances okay but does not
buzz but does voice acting not
give you emotion yeah the voice acting
does okay so how come music can't do
that
dude i don't know i guess i can't like i
don't know it doesn't connect with me i
don't know
do you know a medium where you can feel
emotion just by story
and characters books books
you don't read books i don't want to
read the book i want someone to read it
for me
the music for me is something that like
ties it together and it's something that
if it's done well i don't notice and if
it's done badly i will notice
okay no i agree with that which is the
way i think that most people view
like voice acting no no i agree with how
if music is done well
i don't if it's done so well then
sometimes you can't notice it but
but then there's a level no because i
don't i don't look out for it like i i
don't see
no when i say when i say good i mean
like just it blends in perfectly yeah
satisfactory music you don't notice it
yeah but
you will definitely hear when a
soundtrack is really well there's a
track that they use in amazing ways i'll
notice that track and i'll like have
like a little
logo right but does that not like your
emotions you've definitely heard
the sarino drop yeah yeah and i'm like
oh yeah i get a little hype
about it i'm like
excited
[Laughter]
go protagonist
oh my god have you ever watched like
okay my my favorite soundtrack of what's
up is probably
zankye no tedda or terian resonance i
remember enjoying that show a lot
okay so i remember the music was sad i
don't know
when you talk about music to me you need
to filter it through like the youtube
audio library
tags like genre and mood that's the only
thing i understand about music
tell me the genre of music and the mood
it was okay you watched
it yeah i love those guys okay it had
the whole icelandic
uh like kind of post rock drone rider
the motorbike scene where they're on
like the motor and it's nothing
but just no doubt no dialogue just them
riding on a motorbike with
beautiful visuals and beautiful music do
you remember that scene now
i remember them being terrorists this is
i'm
feeling so [ __ ] frustrated now oh my
god
i just remember them being like
terrorists right and it was fun anime
you remember them
i remember them blowing up [ __ ] that's
like saying attack on titans i remember
the being titans
yeah there's titan dude i remember
enjoying that show but like
when i finished like it's gone okay okay
okay then
let's let's steer away let's go down
let's go down to the most like
rudimentary level here let's let's go to
okay okay what is your favorite anime
opening
oh that's good i really like the kogius
one okay why
type is fun okay but what makes it like
like what emotions do you feel
when listening to it is it excitement is
it like are you excited yeah okay
so how come you can put emotion into
that song
but what what makes what makes that
memorable yeah what makes that matter
yeah the
the opening part is pretty high you know
the the the jumbo
that's just the meme yeah i love it
though it's good what else do i love i
mean the jojo the jojo opening type is
fun
okay okay oh no no giona gianno's theme
okay why does
as i said in i think i tweeted it i was
like it's the bohemian rhapsody
what does that mean what does that mean
what is that because there's so much
[ __ ] going on it's like a five minute
song and there's just like so many
[ __ ] things happening
and i'm like wow this is amazing
i don't know if it's the coffee or this
conversation but i'm basically getting a
headache
i'm getting like a brain aneurysm right
now i imagine the viewers at home are
like what is wrong with this kid what's
wrong i'm like dying inside just
listening to this ah
have i never had this conversation with
you before because every time you bring
up music i think i just go like yeah
okay
you if we went to school together you
would be that one kid who would wear a
cocobain t-shirt not knowing who nirvana
was
i mean like to be like yeah i like his
face yeah look he's like
that teen spirit song spirit yeah what
is it
looks like teen spirit so
okay what else do you value anything
else in an anime
aside from like story and characters
then um i mean the visuals are really
important
right like i feel that it's like it's
it's not so much that i don't appreciate
music it's again like i said like if
it's done well
it blends in and i don't really pay much
attention to it okay but you remember
the cowboy ball soundtrack yeah
okay why do you remember that i remember
it went like really well with all the
cardio like the
all the movements in that show like
blended so well yeah music and i
remember
it like made them both stand out more
than anything at the time when i was
watching right
because the choreo so your argument is
that because this
the feeling of the soundtrack is not an
argument so completely
i'm just saying like i'm not trying to
argue or anything i'm just saying that's
what i remember is because no no no
because because you kind of
because you're logic from what i'm
understanding your logic is
that again i don't think about this too
much yeah well your logic is that the
cowboy bebop soundtrack you remember
because the feeling and vibe you got
from the music was so different to the
visuals
right no no because i can't put the
visuals without the music there
okay so how come you don't remember
zankyeon ortera then
because it does the exact same thing i
remember like maybe like
two scenes from sankyonotera literally
and do they involve any music
no i remember seeing the building
explode
i was about to say the only sound i
remember
i remember someone getting sniped and i
remember being
sad by the sniped i i was expecting to
say that you were very impressed with
the no script i was very interested
with this man's aim in a helicopter very
impressed you know must have had some
very
background okay like when i watch a show
that was good but not like life-changing
it kind of just goes
in the back of my head and i remember
like well apparently if you watch
life-changing shows you don't remember
the music anyway so
it's like i remember the boca rano theme
i remember the pokemon
everyone knows that song though that's
all i remember from boca rato the music
though
so you don't remember the soundtrack no
not at all i remember the soundtrack
being pretty good to book arona
no clue um actually i don't remember
that yeah i i just remember the opening
this man doesn't remember one single
soundtrack because
because after after last episode or
sorry a couple of episodes back uh
i went and re-watched a couple of
episodes of volcarano just because i
hadn't seen it in such a long time and
the sound i remember the soundtrack i
was like wow this soundtrack
for sure really [ __ ] good it's like
for some reason i cannot for the life of
me
remember character names after the end
of the show like
i'm just like it's the blue haired one
and he does something
it's not even monkey breeze it's
goldfish i
genuinely like it's so weird because
i'll remember so many things vividly in
my life but when it comes to
entertainment and stuff that i consume
it's like
it goes i mean i guess that's good
because you probably just
infinite rewatch ability right yeah yeah
i can re-watch shows and not get
enjoyment out there
i forget what because i forget half the
[ __ ] that i've seen right
like uh what are they we watched
something recently and i remember being
like
very impressed because i'm like i forgot
all right we watched breaking bad and i
was like i forgot
all of this [ __ ] yeah through seasons
one through five i don't remember
anything i mean that's a long show so
that makes sense
yeah but yeah that's i don't know is
that weird i'm sure there's people in
the comments who are the same were like
don't remember any characters i don't
remember the soundtracks i've i've met
i've met someone
why are you watching adam yeah i love
the experience like
leave me alone i get what i get out of
it you enjoy the experience that you
don't remember after hands
do you remember this i've legitimately
never had this conversation
yeah like this this conversation is the
first to me i've never i've never had to
explain
to someone why music is like a good
thing no no no no no in terms of
entertainment no i'm not i'm not arguing
that it's not a good
thing i just don't remember it okay i'm
convinced right that people
lie about like when you have discussions
with them and you're like yeah you
remember the soundtrack i'm just
convinced that they're just like yeah
yeah yeah it was totally great i mean
like the sun there's
like definitely people who do that all
the time no but like to say there's like
not a single soundtrack
from like some of your favorite series i
can't remember anything
but if you hear it if i hear it i reckon
i'll be able to pull out that memory
from the
dusty old cabinet right but then you'll
pull it out and what you'll pull out a
file that just says good
i'm like nice but it's like okay it's
like
i can remember voice performances quite
well but that's because i
i take an active interest in really
learning those and really studying that
so what do you sell makes a good voice
performance then
and is it something that has to be in
english or does it have
can you recognize it in like japanese
yeah japanese too but i think that's
just from watching a lot of japanese
media
yeah it's something that you can because
the way you deliver a line
anything right the way i visu a line
there's a uh when you deliver a singular
line there's a visualization to it of
if you imagine the pacing and the pitch
like they should in my head
with a good line there's a set where it
should be delivered right and that's the
way the director wants it to and
i imagine like someone like quentin
tarantino has the same idea it's like
the line is delivered
the way i see it yeah right and so it's
like
i just visualize in my head the way it
should go like if you should raise your
voice how you should raise your pitch
and then
when you should take it down when you
should slow it down when you should out
of pause
and it's really interesting seeing how
like some of the actors will deliver a
certain line and where they'll choose to
take pauses
or how they'll choose to slow words down
i think that's really interesting
oh i'm the same like you know i haven't
done as much voicing yeah as you but
yeah
i definitely take a keen eye to voice
acting as well because i also want to
get better at it yeah and i i i
totally get what you mean with the cult
curve there's the way i wish that like
i wish i had figured out a way where i
could definitively show people what i
mean in my head
right yeah about that because if you put
the line on like an axis of y and
like x you know they would it would go
like that right yeah
it would be like right you need to pause
here you need to take a break here slow
down this word this word's in italics so
please put emphasis on it but not too
much emphasis yeah very bold
yeah it's like really loads of nuances
that we don't see as the audience that
i'm trying
in my head when i'm listening to
something i'm imagining how they saw the
script
yeah i'm trying to think back to what
they were thinking so like
depending on what medium we're in now
like and also
ever since i got way too into voice
acting i see so much adr and it puts me
the [ __ ] off in films when you can hear
one line that's delivered in the room
yep and one line whether you get it in
post
yeah it's so grating when you hear
because like so many sitcoms do this
where they like have the line done in
post yeah you don't realize how many
movies are done in post as well i don't
know a lot of you have done so well then
yeah yeah i've definitely noticed it
recently when i was like
yeah like when you noticed it once you
can't stop noticing it
i noticed and and that's the problem i
have with um
watching shows that are dubbed in
languages like
uh you know italian or whatever or or
dutch normally
they're they have to dub so many shows
where they're just pumping this out and
there's not really much given to the
sound of it and it sounds like
everyone's
in a studio every single tv show they're
in no matter where they go
when i hear this italian or this dutch
guy speak it always sounds like they're
in a studio when they're outside it's
like what the [ __ ] i hate that
so much and that's the reason why when
people are like oh i watched
i had a german friend who watched game
of thrones in dutch or a german sorry
dubbed
and i was like why it sounds like
everyone's in a studio they want a
battlefield no
it's exactly the same as thai dubs when
i was talking about
dubs and they just don't know audio
mixing so instead of like making it
sound like they're in the environment
they're in
it's always in the same studio and
instead of like mixing in the voices
they just like quiet
every other voice and every other sound
every other sound so the voices are just
like 10 times louder than every sound
effect every time someone talks and then
the sound effects get louder again oh my
god it's like the worst kind of audio
mixing
that's lazy as [ __ ] yeah i mean now
i'm not sure if they did it back then
but now commonly the japanese uh
studios will just give uh basically a
track with just
the voices taken out yeah and they're
like here's everything we've done it all
for you
just add the voices yeah normally quite
easy um but yeah but the
in terms of dubbing or voice
performances in anime
cartoons that's a whole different like
yeah i feel like i feel like one
unsung hero in terms of like voice
acting and dubbing is the voice director
because i i feel like obviously you know
actors get
a lot of the credits but i feel they
also get all the [ __ ] they always get
all the [ __ ]
and i feel like the a voice director has
so much control
over how good this voice performance is
going to be because i've definitely
worked with voice actors and actresses
in my own bridge series
where they've done a great [ __ ] job
and then i i see them voicing like other
projects
and it's terrible it's it's bad yeah it
hurts me because i know
the potential that these voice actors
have um and i know that
it's probably just bad voice direction
you know and they're gone
and a lot of people don't think about
that or don't know that because they
just think oh that
it's a shitty voice actor you know yeah
it's a real shame
it's difficult because unless you've
been in an environment where you've
worked with a director
or had someone directing you in any way
it's really hard to understand the role
of a director
yes i didn't quite get it until i had
worked in that space
and it's kind of the person who like
because when you're doing it for
yourself and you're acting
you're in your own head you're your
worst enemy because you're like [ __ ] i
should've done it this way
because when i've recorded for one of my
own videos 20 takes
i record for someone else with a
director one or two texts yeah because
they tell me what they want and they
help me get there and a lot of people
like there's ten percent of voice actors
who can deliver lines
amazingly without a director yeah but
then there's like 50 who need a director
yeah and there's like 30 40 percent who
let's be honest
but it's one of those things where you
do need like a good ear somewhat it's a
skill
absolutely it's definitely a skill
because i personally think i'm a much
better voice director than i am a voice
yeah yeah yeah
even though i've done both i try to like
insert my own voice as little as
possible whenever i'm
doing kind of any kind of voice work
that i've done before
but i really enjoy directing because
it's it's it's definitely
a unique skill because i've seen how
other people direct
their their work as well and it's
everyone has a different style
some are just not effective at all some
some
some voice directors you know they they
have no idea what they want no
you know and yeah it's just on the voice
actor to save
to save the performance somehow even
though the director has no idea what
they want
um do you ever get that moment though
when you're directing someone
and you they've not delivered the line
exactly the way you want it and so you
have to explain it to them
and you get to the third point yeah the
third it's
the third time the third time you've
tried and they still
haven't done it the way you want it to
do
do you continue like do you do you
continue trying to explain it to them or
do you just go with one of the takes
normally i will do i would try my best
to explain it to them
yeah um worst case scenario i'll do
a line read which line read is uh you
don't normally do it it's kind of
it's not unprofessional but it wastes a
lot of time which is where the director
will deliver the line
and he'll be like just copy what i just
did yeah and that's what i'll do on the
worst case scenario
and if they can't do that then it's like
[ __ ]
this is going to be bad like if they if
they can't hear want like
what i just did yeah and they can't
replicate it that means that they have
no idea what i just did yeah
in my head i'm like okay they don't even
see what i did they don't know what
they're doing
yeah it's the worst feeling in the world
isn't it
it's pretty awful today's video is
sponsored by xenonsard zenonsart is a
unique ai based anime card game for the
mobile that's just been recently
released
so do you guys know what the ai card
game is i have no idea what ai
so basically the ar card game so in the
game you get an ai buddy that you can
choose from and and the choice of the a
but i think there's 16 different ai
characters that you can choose from and
it's based off of this interview that
you do at the beginning of the game that
dictates your personality and right you
pick the ai that best suits your
personality but basically
you have an ai buddy that plays along
and helps you strategize
to play zenon's which is this card game
and the ai buddy like gives you
legitimate advice on the games like how
you can beat the game and like different
strategies and
you don't have to follow the ai but you
know a lot of the ais are
acute girls and sometimes they're just
like really cool characters and you're
like okay you know what you're you're an
ai
i'll listen to you yeah yeah yeah so as
i understand it there's also
500 different cards with seven different
categories and i've also seen a few
clips of the game and the visuals
look pretty damn impressive for a mobile
game so the actual gameplay involves
three phases you have the mono movement
phase the flash phase and the main phase
and the unique feature about zenon zod
is the mana movement system where you
can
move summoned minions to and from mana
in kind of a
really interesting recycling mechanism
so as you play against an ai opponent
you can easily take breaks whenever you
want but you can also play against pvp
as well so if you download the game
right now then you can actually get your
hands on 240 of the 500 cards available
in the game just
off of ongoing events and if you use the
hashtag xenonsat aci
on facebook and twitter you can use that
to connect with other players in the
game or to just
battle and flex your hot ai waifu so if
that sounds interesting to you go down
to the description down below
and download xenon zod today and you
could get up to 240 of the exclusive 500
cards thank you to xenozap for
sponsoring today's episode
and back to the video i did a video
series where i like fixed
uh games hentai anime i redid all the
voice acting from the ground up um and
the only rule was that
i wasn't allowed to change uh i was i
wasn't changing anything
about the voice acting the whole point
of that was to like prove to the viewers
that like
listen you could you can fix the bad
voice acting but more often than not
it's
not the bad voice acting that is
terrible about this series or
thing that you watch like it's normally
just because like everything else is
terrible yeah and the one thing that
stands out is this dude who's delivering
a line [ __ ] like yeah yeah
but that's normally as a result of
everything else being [ __ ] because voice
actors are the last priority for most
things
because they're normally the thing that
you do at the end and some games and
stuff like games
are normally the worst uh worst culprit
of terrible voice acting
oh no no especially japanese games that
get translated into english
normally have god [ __ ] awful voice
actions
a lot of those games as well just have
absolutely horrible
localization just the dialogue clearly
the person who was translating it
does not have the firmest grasp of both
languages and it's because normally
they're not given like
like an amazing budget to do it no these
games are long
pretty underpaid unfortunately yeah so
they're just like whatever i'll just do
the
minimum run it through google translate
if need be you know [ __ ] it no one's
going to notice the voice things
[ __ ] anyway who cares the japanese word
in with like okasan you know
yeah means mom in japanese
all according to keikaku like speaking
about voice actors and voice acting
like the only person who's actually been
in an anime here is you joe yeah yeah
i'm like an actual japanese anime like
what was the experience like for you
then
that was really cool because you want to
explain like you're on pop team episode
yes
yeah so i just purely by coincidence i
got to voice in pop team epic
uh even though all my lines i did were
in english it was technically
it was technically the japanese i'm in
i know because funimation dubbed pop
team epic
and they didn't use me i don't think
they're allowed to though
no they weren't but you know
fundamentally you could've hit me off
my dms were open my dms were we follow
each other on twitter
you could have dm me anyway so i voiced
uh
this it was this entire episode that was
voiced in english because pogba maybe
it's just
crazy no rules right um and it was
really cool because
uh i got to voice act with the guy who
voiced rio in devilman crybaby
oh awesome because he's also fluent in
english he's pretty
good at english oh wow yeah so he and he
delivered obviously in the english part
as well
and it was really cool because it you
know it's a lot of the portrayals is
of voice acting is that you know one
person goes into the booth they do their
lines
next person comes in it's normal that's
normally how it is but i don't know if
this is only in the japanese industry
but at least with the anime
they put all the voice actors that are
in the one
episode all into the same room and there
are four or five microphones lined up
yeah i i saw i saw that with some like
behind the scenes documentary yeah
i think how i understand the dubbing in
like the english speaking world is that
you get one booth
one one one after the other one but in
anime it's
you they do it all in one go so if
there's a current scene
where there are four voice actors then
all four voice actors will go up to the
mics and
basically while holding them the the
script in their hand take it in turns to
deliver their line and when they're not
doing their line they pull away from the
microphone i think
all cartoons used to be that way in the
world yeah i think recently it's changed
i think so i think one series you
definitely see that effect in
is conoceber where you can you can tell
that all of the characters are just like
bouncing off each other oh yeah
so much yeah and like the dub the dub
for conor super is actually great
and i commend them for being able to
like recreate this energy while not
being in the same room because because
you can definitely feel that energy in
the japanese dub i mean connoisseur oh
yeah that's what makes one of it's
that that's why it's so good because you
can tell that these aren't just
characters that are [ __ ] around with
one another but yeah
voice actors that are just having a
great time yeah exactly and you need
that dynamic in a show like that yeah
and but it was really cool because with
pop team epic
uh you know we would all come on to one
scene you know there was me
you know the main voice actor and then
there was like three or four voice
actors who were doing
you know just side characters yeah and
it was really cool because once a scene
would finish
then if one of us needed a retake or it
was really cool because all of the voice
actors would come together and basically
critique
what we all just did in that one song
that's cool so that we would all come
together and i would get
you know professional advice from the
the voice actor or being like
okay that lion deliver was really cool
but maybe if you deliver this next line
like this
then i could respond in this kind of way
oh okay and while all of this
conversation is happening
the voice director is also listening in
so he can put in the input of his right
if need be
um so i mean i didn't have to do too
many retakes with pop team epic because
the voice actor was just like yeah
that's good he just did not give a [ __ ]
right he was just like yeah good enough
[ __ ] whatever i mean like you you're
speaking in english so he was like yeah
this this probably sounds better than
right most of the english voice actors
the only time that the voice actor asked
me to do
the voice director asked me to do
something super specific was when i had
to do
the narrator voice uh for the guilty
gear parody scene where i had to say
heaven or hell
like in guilty gear and he was like no
no because the voice director was like a
massive fan of guilty
so he's like no no that's not how you
say it you have to say like this and you
just
boom it over the pr system all
okay i'll do it like that i guess that
sounds like such a fun experience oh it
was super fun
were you nervous doing it oh hell yeah
because
literally everybody else around me are
professional japanese voice actors
but it was really cool because all of
the voice actors were like wow how long
have you been doing voice acting i was
like i
this is my first day technically
speaking this is my first gig
and they were like you're really [ __ ]
good i was like well
call your boy back and then everyone
cheered
everyone lifted joey up
i was like subscribe damn dude i do i've
had some terrible [ __ ] clients
did a lot of commercials because they
would bring in like a business executive
right to come in and critique and they
don't [ __ ] know anything
right and they would i remember one time
there was a guy and
i did this whole take and i thought i
killed it
and he was like yeah something's like
off with it this wasn't the director
this was just the guy who was paying for
it to be made
and he was like yeah could you just try
something different i did the exact same
thing again
no different and he was like that was
perfect and i was like i was like i
[ __ ] knew it
because like i know okay i in my head
i'm like i know i can get away with
doing the same thing
one more time but like maybe not a
second time so i was like i'll just try
once see if he notices he had no idea
yeah at that point onwards any time he
said anything i would just look at the
voice director
over there i would look at him i'm like
should i listen to this
like he was the engineer and the
director of the thing right yeah
which he so he normally does the deliver
uh the way i the way it was set up for
me was he normally directed me and the
client would just stand there and go
like
yes yes like because i was always doing
business stuff
right it was like it was like
perseverance inspiration
[ __ ] like that you did like a gillette
commercial right or it wasn't
like a like a shaving cream commercial
whatever it was something
it was ages ago i was doing like
boats for like a year you did both i did
like uh
there was some i can't i don't know what
the corporation is and i also don't know
if i should say i don't know if i'm
allowed i don't know what i signed i
[Laughter]
once a week i would go in for three
hours and i would talk about
boats wait how old were you this was
like last year oh really
every week i went in and talked about i
was in london right yes it was in london
yeah
yeah i got paid like [ __ ] like how much
was it they were paying me
250 pounds an hour oh wow uh which is
like 300 something bucks
yeah just talk about boats which is
probably like a lot better than what
voice actors get paid to voice an anime
yeah definitely uh yeah anime rates
aren't that great i mean i don't i don't
know if
you know i'm gonna i'll just say like i
mean i definitely didn't get paid
i've heard things and uh i you know you
get paid on
funimation from what i've been told i
don't know if this is true i don't know
i'm allowed to say this but it's not
it's not great it's not
i feel less than what i was getting yeah
i mean i it's like i think it's always
just been known that the voice
acting industry in anime specifically
just like paid the least
yeah you get paid the lease out of any
commercial which is why you see a lot of
dubbed voice actors going on to do
gaming now yeah
industries the the way it goes is like
it's like uh
normally commercials pay the most
because commercials you get paid
normally a premium and then you also get
what's called a buyout fee
so if your ad is going to be played over
x amount of places with radios tv that
gets calculated in the cost yeah and you
could get like
one commercial that takes you 20 minutes
which it often did because commercials
are
30 seconds long mostly and i would never
be there for more than 30 minutes
but they would maybe pay you like 15
grand for the biopsy
so your session fee was like 250 pounds
yeah but then you might get 15 grand or
10.
depending on where they play it and how
much because i know the guy who did
mcdonald's ads in the uk that was his
whole career yeah he's doing mcdonald's
really yeah because you got
he got paid so far oh yeah it is
mcdonald's game like six figures every
commercial
because you know that's luckily how the
industry was that you got paid if your
voice was being could you imagine
getting paid six
figures by going but i wish right
that's the thing he was like imagine how
much how much money mcdonald's made off
of
because normally how it is with
commercials is that if you're
normally with voices if a corporation
gets one voice actor it's normally
always that one voice actor who does
everything so
in the industry where i when i was in
london it was mainly commercial stuff so
it came up a lot and it was always like
people were competing
to get that one commercial gig that kept
coming yeah and so i got this boat gig
and i didn't think of anything of it um
because i didn't audition they like
requested me so i went in i did a read
for it and i was talking about
um i had to explain a ton of different
things about large ships
for a corporation okay and i had to go
in every week and do something
ballasting that was what i did like
[ __ ] four weeks of thing called
ballasting right
ballasting is a thing and i know this
because i did four scripts
sell us a bit what what is ballasting
sir he was like it was like it was like
god i wish i remembered the words
and i remember every time i would go in
to deliver it because my accent is
is english right but it's not uh receive
pronunciation which is the
typical accent which is i say grass but
it's grass
so every time i would do anything he's
like you didn't you didn't say the the
received pronunciation
do it again i'm like oh yes of course
ballasting you know is the you know like
that
and it was basically where water goes in
the ships and they dunk it dump it out
later on okay but there was like so many
scientific words and i was like
it was the the sodium hydrosis oxide
oxygenation thing and i was like all
right
the hard thing about that is that you
could do a thing called line reading
where
they're paying you to get this right the
first time yeah so the first time i see
the script is when i go in there
yeah and i'm sure that was at the same
for you with popped humans you could see
it beforehand
with pop team epic i got sent not only
the script about
three weeks before i went in yeah but i
also got a cd
with [ __ ] the actual visuals that's like
amazing
so i can practice ahead of time and
apparently that's normal in the anime
industry
that's that's just like the japanese
trust system yeah i mean like it's like
we
trust that you will not leak this that
just sounds like a leak waiting to
happen because i didn't any other i
didn't sign a contract
either yeah they just got sent this
without an ending
they just sent it to me hoping that i
wouldn't leave this bro i
i i can maybe count on my hands the
amount of time
i received the script before i got there
like yeah it was like
never really yeah and so i would get the
script in front of me i'd maybe have two
minutes to quickly go over it
but they immediately expected me to like
nail it first time and again there's
words
i've never even seen the english
language they come up in these scripts
right
i don't know what these words are but
i'm expected to like nail it whilst i'm
also reading it for the first time
and that's what they're paying you an
absurd amount of money like i know
[ __ ] people who run like official
discords for like bandai or something
you have to sign ndas
yeah and here you are just actually
voice
getting it the entire script is episode
nine
six months before it comes out good luck
no it was crazy like i got it in the
mail they didn't even tell me they were
going to send it because i was also
assuming that i was going to see the
script and everything yeah
when i got that's not how it is yeah
right that's what i heard about dubbing
do that as well
yeah that's what i heard but not only
that but when i when i also cameoed uh
in the uh grissiah phantom trigger
game yeah they also sent me the script
like two weeks beforehand as well
they didn't send me the visuals but they
sent me the script like the physical
script and i had to go in with my
physical script i think the difference
is
normally in the western industries
they're still editing the script like
the day off
yeah like so normally the script that
you get might not even be the final
draft
also people don't trust anyone in the
world which is which is
of course you know this is this is the
country the way you can leave like your
[ __ ] laptop in the middle of a diner
go to the bathroom and then come back
and just trust that nobody's gonna take
it yeah
you know i just wanted to leak the boat
stuff i don't even care i just want to
leak it
no one can i just want to leak it don't
get it don't tell anybody but they use
sodium hydroxide
yeah that it's crazy but i mean you know
did you get paid well for the both thing
though oh yeah i got paid really well oh
yeah but that's like that's like the
voice actors stream is
i didn't i didn't i didn't do it for the
money i should because it was fun yeah
well that's yeah same with me like
i i feel like people who go into
especially like the anime industry to
who wants to be a voice actor
they do it for the passion you get paid
nothing for those sessions
i mean maybe unless you're a sag actor
yeah you get paid a decent amount i
think it's 250 dollars minimum for a
session two-hour session
um but yeah it's you get the notoriety
which allows you to do a lot
yeah right yeah i don't know because i
feel like nowadays
there's less notoriety and like big
voice acting names yeah
in dubbing at least than than they're
used to true they used to be cons right
that's what you wanted
yeah yeah yeah exactly but now like if
even if you get to voice a dub in like a
huge huge show there's like you still
don't get as much notoriety as like say
um back in like the mid-2000s where you
had voice actors like steve bloom johnny
bosch chrisman freeman who just like
those those like the triple a
yeah everybody knew who they were yeah
yeah exactly but it's it's a lot
harder in this climate in the industry
just because there's
there's so many dubs now yeah yeah
everything gets slimed
like if it's on funimation it's probably
going to be slime or dubbed and
everyone watches anime in like very
different ways now
yeah i mean like like even even going
back to japan since where
i i didn't know who any of the voice
actors who voiced in this anime were
because i was like
i was literally switching between dub
and sub depending on which one i like to
listen to
um because i feel like the voice acting
for dubs in general has has gotten into
like like possible quality
in almost every show like there are
there are some shows that are like
this is this is just a funny dub you
know for the most part
if i want to just shut my brain off and
just listen to the language that i want
that i speak then i just i'll just put
on dub and i can i have the trust that
it will be
like a decent experience yeah dubs have
definitely gotten to that point yeah
yeah there's there's certainly no like
90s quality like hilarious dub
no no no no yeah i feel like the whole
argument of sub versus dub is kind of
like you to this point i feel like the
counterpoint to that is that
there are less dubs that just stand out
now
yeah because i i think of some of my
favorite dubs right something like
baccano that's best time
you know cowboy these are dubs that
stand out like literally like
i i remember how good they were just
because of how their quality but
nowadays i don't know i can't think i
can't think of like many dubs that
literally just
okay this everything's good everything's
off decent quality but i can't think of
anything that like
truly stands out this is a dub
experience to me the last
i think the newest the newest quote
unquote anime where the dub was like
wow was probably panty and stalky yeah
but that was like 2008 yeah
that's what i'm saying newest in
quotations
it's how the industry was back then
right you had like two weeks to just
cast people like you had two weeks just
for that let alone everything else but
now it's
you have two weeks to not even two weeks
like one week so
cast translate and get these actors in
the booth and get recording like it's
you you can't expect anything good to
come out of that you you can
we get the good products right it's
decent but we're not gonna get anything
that blows us away from it
i think the last current industry the
last dub that blew me away was probably
stein's gate because yeah it's it was
one of those shows where i actually
i could appreciate the work that went
into translating and just scripting it
yeah not just like the voice acting but
like everything was just
really polished i didn't believe that
was scripted by
marketing yeah yeah oh really yeah yeah
yeah which is which is why he
absolutely killed it uh as well so like
because i think with the era of cyber
dubbing
it's just it's a lot harder to recreate
that same quality at the same height
because
they just don't have as much time
anymore i also think at least for
funimation i think when sony took over i
think they restructured a lot of it
to make it less focused on giving
uh riders time and more giving like
getting the whole thing out sooner
yeah which you know is understandable i
guess but also at the same time you kind
of lose a bit of that magic that
you know maybe a dub would be whoa you
know what i mean yeah
actually here's here's a question for
you joey because you you could probably
judge us the best but
ever since the beginning of time there's
always been this debate of subs versus
dubs you know
the japanese japanese voice acting is
always great
has there been any show or any anime
from your experience that it's just
bad voice acting from like a japanese
side of things
man that's hard to say because at least
with voice from my understanding in my
experience
at least japanese voice acting in anime
yeah has just
had an insanely high bar to jump over oh
now
even ever since even you know like i
could obviously go back to you know an
anime from the 70s
yeah yeah and probably find some bad
voice acting there but that's because
it was a medium that was still getting
refined since the 60s right yeah
but i think honestly every anime i've
seen
since you know the late 80s early 90s
i don't think there's been a maybe
there's been like one or two bad voices
or one or two maybe like
under qualified voices compared to
everybody else in that same show but
i wouldn't say there's an entire show
that has like bad voice acting being the
same way that there are bad dubs
yeah exactly but and i don't know maybe
that's like a cultural thing maybe
i think it's because they've set up a
system here that ensures they're getting
voice talent right yeah
yeah they have schools specifically for
voice action yeah yeah we don't really
have that in the world
it's you go to acting school and maybe
you stumble into voice over right if
that's what you like
there's not really a system but their
entire you know like four year
universities no right exactly
say yes it's the same reason why like
korea are normally amazing at esports
they have the infrastructure there to
support
like making this talent yeah yeah and
you know in japan obviously you
they've been having those schools for a
while where the bar is getting pushed
constantly and constantly
yeah whereas it's not really like that
in the west exactly
and and you know the the great thing as
well with the structure of at least the
japanese voice acting in anime is that
if there is a new voice actor or actress
that comes into the industry
they usually start them off with very
very small roles maybe like one line or
even just background noise to kind of
get them used to that environment
and give them as much experience as
possible and then maybe after they do
you know
ten roles of playing you know person
passing behind
the main character after the tenth time
then they can give them
overall awareness it's very japanese
yeah there's two more lines
okay the next one will give you five
lines yes we'll give you ten lines and
then it just builds and builds from
there unless
if it's someone that just has insane
amount of talent from the get-go
yeah they're just confident enough to
put them into a show and then they make
a name for themselves because
some of the best dub performances have
been from actors where like they weren't
acting in any other animated shows oh no
yeah
i i think i think um i think johnny and
bosh
like stumbled into his first dub role by
accident
um i think same with steve bloom as well
uh yeah i think so
from what i found out it's been a while
since i heard the stories
like both fantastic voices yeah god
i think oh was the guy who did light in
the death note dub he did a lot of the
ocean dubs in canada he did like yeah
because he did rock from black lagoon as
well
i think he was doing my little pony
before really
don't think you've done anything i know
the guy voices lad rousseau in baccano i
hadn't done any animation no no i
remember a lot of like back then a lot
of the
voice actors who voiced in baccano was
that was like their first role
yes everyone [ __ ] killed it you know
yeah it was really there's a lot of
unknown voice actors
uh and actresses in that in in that show
great show yeah questions
questions to you guys then we've so with
the ridiculously high bar
that japanese voice acting has what are
what are some shows that
eat you know that even stand up for you
with like the
japanese voice talent and voice acting
i'll tell you the show that stands out
to me most recently yeah and that's b
stars
oh yeah b stars has absolutely like
insane voice acting
and it's very different because it
doesn't it doesn't it didn't sound like
your typical
anime kind of voice acting it sounded
very grounded
i don't know who the voice actor for
lego c is but his his acting was
so good like lego and luis yeah
was like they both had like the voice
acting performances of that year oh any
anime easily easily in in my in my
opinion like eve
even with shows like attack on titan
three coming out that had some great
voice acting
i still think b stars was like just a
cut above the rest
i think it's just because b stars as a
show was just a cut above the rest
yeah yeah yeah like it was just such a
[ __ ] amazing show i'm trying to think
of any japanese shows that really blew
me away with voice actors jojo
i mean my mandio kills it
like that perform i i spoke about this
before like his performance like this
dear like i'm not memes aside like
it's [ __ ] amazing oh yeah he's
[ __ ] great and
everyone in part five i would argue as
well has fantastic voices
i think i think the thing with japanese
voices was that
they can just do casting so well yeah
they get it yeah
they understand how important casting is
for a character oh
i'm working on a video right now and
like i watched the clan ad dub and
there's just one scene where a female
teacher is just
voiced by a dude what really yeah yeah
like
i'm i'll it's i obviously can't show
this but i'll show you guys later at all
i mean this is why i didn't watch a dog
it's just like a scene i
watched it dumb so i don't remember this
but i watched someone sent me the clip
and i'm like
that's just a dude hi boys
it's like what how did this pass
i mean there was a lot of weird things
that happened with dubbing back in the
day if we're going to talk about bad
dubs
yeah exactly you know we have to talk
about you know like ghost stories
ghost stories is that a bad dub or is
that it's so
bad that it's good people people always
act because when i when i tweet out be
like hey i'm going to fix bad anime
scenes for a youtube video people always
be like yeah fix ghost stories i'm like
what is it
there's nothing to fix this is amazing
it's [ __ ] great
it's it's just because i from what i've
heard about how ghost stories came to be
made it was ghost stories just sold
horribly in japan so when they licensed
it oh license they're over they were
like yeah
do what you need to do to make this sell
yeah like dude
you have there was so much creative
control yeah there were some rules but
you basically you basically had full
creative control
and from what i heard like they were
just the voice actors would just
try to rush in the booth first and they
would just like ad-lib the scenes yeah
and everyone else would have to like
play off what they said yeah
it was like the first of bridge yeah
yeah yeah essentially i mean
yeah it's it's weird to think right that
dubs back in the 70s
were done where there was no email
like how did they do this they were
literally a guy was given this dvd and
they just kind of
made it i know they just and the
japanese just hoped they did it well
like you know
it's weird right do you think there was
even then it was a trust system yeah
yeah yeah they're like i guess just take
this dvd and
go home yeah vhs
[Music]
it's weird but even i think that's also
why some dubs now are a bit strange
because
they were still done on that system
where if you go first
you dub it and then the person who comes
next has to dub
but they get to hear just your character
who's been before you so right yeah that
was last normally is the easiest time
right yeah and that because they have to
kind of go along with oh they perform
this character in this way so i kind of
have to do it the same
but if the first one sucks it's a bit
unfortunate because i think it makes
this weird kind of feeling sometimes by
accident but this is again why a
director should be on top of that [ __ ]
yeah yeah
that's that's what that's why like the
director has control
over how this sounds because there are
definitely some dubs where it definitely
sounds like people aren't having a
conversation
yeah yeah i've always said i think a
director's job is like 10 to get the
best performance out of you and like
90 to make sure everyone sounds like
they're in the same world like that's
the hardest part
because you're constantly thinking like
okay that was a great line but does it
fit with what the other person just
delivered yeah like i need to think
about that yeah
it's a really hard skill it's it's it's
definitely hard because you have to be
on top of what everyone is saying and
how everyone sounds and
it's it's definitely like you can
definitely see some of the new answers
that
people don't normally think about but if
you if you play a conversation and it's
just like man these people just sound
like they're reading lines to each other
and not actually having a conversation
and it's really it just sounds yeah it's
that uncanny valley yeah
it sounds like they're kind of talking
through dimensions
one's living in one world and the other
was living in the other world and the
rift just happened to open up where it's
like oh hello
oh hi mark hi mark god man
i could see her and talk all day about
dubbed anime and voice acting and all
that because
obviously that's what i'm cripplingly
addicted to
apparently not music yeah not music
we're gonna get this boy on some like
we gotta make him understand emotions i
never thought i'd say that
i just i wish like i wish kevin was here
i wish kevin was like guessing in this
one
kevin
his reaction when you were just saying
all this stuff as a [ __ ] composer
kevin if you're watching this i want you
to just like if
we ever get kevin on the show and we
will get kevin on the show just
i want to just hear the conversation
look him in the eye i want you to
look him in the eye and just be like
made an abyss soundtrack made me feel
good
i'll do it just dead-ass look in the
video and just be like i don't remember
any of your music but it made me feel
good
i heard the sounds i mean i i feel like
i have the opposite brain to like a
composer though in like every aspect
like when i talk to kevin
i feel like i'm on like the complete
opposite
mind in every way it's crazy it's so
weird i think i'd have that that kind of
mind that isn't isn't like that
i mean if we can't even like relate to
we're not exactly composers
i feel like you're you're very musical
though right i mean yeah
but i'm no kevin penkins no right but
you have an appreciation for music
something that i don't have
yeah i i can't make music it doesn't
make sense to me i don't understand any
of that
like i tried to learn drums as a kid and
i was like
yes this just doesn't work do you follow
along with like different anime
directors
and like if you said their names maybe
so if i said hosoda momoro
no if i said shinkai makoto
yes okay your name yeah
i know that one wait you don't know jose
mourinho no
have you never seen wolf children's
children summer wars i've seen some of
the digimon movie
i didn't watch that who would the [ __ ]
watch the digital jokes i'm going to
piss
[ __ ] awesome it's a joke don't kill
me
summer walls and boy and the beast boy
and the beast
he also did a one-piece movie what's the
jumping through time or something what's
up what's that one
he also did you know he also directed
the samurai shampoo opening
really yeah okay he also directed a one
piece movie as well one piece movie six
i think that was such good
i know that was [ __ ] great i loved it
did you watch the digimon movie when you
were a kid yeah do you remember the
soundtrack for that yes they had [ __ ]
bare naked ladies
do you remember that scene with all-star
[ __ ] all-star in
it yeah i'm i'm totally serious
we had smash mouth how did they get
these rights because it was back in it
it was like back in the day of like 90s
movies
it was like they had a completely
different soundtrack from the japanese
release yeah so when they when they like
dubbed it and westernized it they put
all these like
western bands i i couldn't because i
watched the japanese movie first
obviously but then
i went to a friend's place and he only
had the dub for it yeah i was like i've
never seen a dub so i might as well
watch it
and then when i heard smash math i was
like
you guys playing a prank did you overdub
this with shrek
i want to now just watch this movie just
to experience
mouthwash smash mouth and fat boy slam
yeah dude hearing fat boy slim i was
like what was it
so surreal no it was because i didn't
realize how special it was when i was
watching it as a kid
but now growing up i i think back and i
realized man this was a really
weird soundtrack in kindergarten they've
got coke on the table
just hearing weapon of choice in a
digimon movie i was like
you're just hearing fat boy slaying like
takes me back 10 years [ __ ] a lot fat
boy slim dude that boy seems [ __ ]
great from brighton by the way
as a born and bred by titanian yeah
from my hope from my hometown
any famous people from where you're from
connor i think there was uh lost profits
that band but then i think they were
like pedophiles so
we quickly uh quickly were abandoned
there was a band called layout it's
called lost profits and i think they
were like a
[ __ ] i don't know they were like kind
of like a knockoff of uh
like some way i i think i remember lost
profits
like the rock band that like was like
british fallout boy sort of
ish oh like panic at the disco kind of
vibe
a little more rocky i think but yeah oh
okay
yeah i was actually i was watching a new
anime recently have you guys heard of
the great pretender
it's i have heard of it yes song no no
no no no no no no okay
there's an anime called the great
pretender [ __ ] i've only seen the
first three episodes
it's like a netflix exclusive anime but
it's it seems like
it's it's [ __ ] great it's i saw a
preview for that i want to watch that
it's it's a heist show
that sets in america okay yeah exactly
you're like
do you when you think of heist show and
anime i think of leap leap on the third
right yeah this i can't think of
many other heist shows but they actually
the ending for that song
is the great pretender by freddie
mercury oh like
he was i remember watching and i was
like well who who is this this kind of
sounds like
queen and i thought i know he is the
actual great pretender by freddie
mercury
i know right i know i sometimes wanted
that because
there's there's a few anime series where
they've gotten western songs yeah right
like um
what's what's uh paradise paradise kiss
uh that france
ferdinand yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
do you want to buy france no no no no
and you know like ergo proxy ending was
paranoid android by radiohead
and uh oasis yeah that was [ __ ]
surreal oh that was such a good opening
though holy [ __ ] you know the east
opening
as someone great show that was a great
show that was a really good show but the
opening to me i love everything stands
out the most
oh yeah probably one of my favorite
openings of all time you know
you know i mean you know we're in a good
mood when either gone or not i put that
on
karaoke we're just like oh let's go baby
it's such a good song no it's great
because these are like the songs
i could put on on karaoke and just
pretend like i can you know sing
an
animation
i'm a weep i'm a wee bell yeah like when
was the last time
that an anime had like a western song
in it like before great pretender was it
was it ergo proxy
it might have been there's been a lot
it's got to be some like we don't know
i don't know if there's like i can't
think of my head like how many um
actual english songs because there's
there's been japanese songs
or there's been japanese bands that have
sunk english you know what i mean but
in terms of actual pure here is like a
western band
who who is just got a got a song and now
there's also that anime from like the
early 2000s i just remember that how was
the duran duran song as the opening oh
yeah that was what the [ __ ] was that
that was
that was that it was the camera one the
camera one yeah what the [ __ ] was it
yeah
it was girls on film by duran duran
no no no speed grappler speed graphics
speed grapher yeah duran duran and like
serial experiments lane as well had this
that had this like really weird unique
british indie bands yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah connor's
just sitting here being like
what's what's going on i've watched like
half of these shows and i'm like oh yeah
they did have that
oh my god i just forget like
how could you think because i listen i'm
like oh that's cool
i'm gonna keep forgetting home of my day
did you skip openings connor
after one watch after one one opening
view i'm like unless it was b stars i
watched it every time yeah yeah that
[ __ ] was like whoa this
yeah actually very specifically then
do you ever okay do you ever notice that
moment
in any anime where it's a really hyped
scene and they play the opening
yeah yeah okay good if you notice that
then you're not
because that's like saying the name of
the show to me
it's like i loved like i don't know why
it always works right but it's not a
type
it's hype you you play the opening song
in any hype scene and it just
brings it from like a 10 to a 20.
it's pretty [ __ ] hype they're about
to pop off yeah yeah
or like you know you know shit's gone
down when it's the end of the episode
and like the end the ending song before
i finish
yeah yeah and you're like oh [ __ ] shit's
about to go down
shit's about to get real like ptsd of
the animal hana song
i was playing and i'm like no no no i i
had that with uh i had that with um
uh uh [ __ ] shinseka yodi when the
[ __ ] uh
when the chorus starts every time it
like every episode
opens with that but then there are a few
episodes near the end where
it kind of yeah from the future world
it's like really good it's 10 out of 10
for me but yeah
the the opening that's that series
didn't have an opening it just had
like this chorus of kids just going ah
i was about to say it like sarcastically
i really like the opening today
i really love uh renai circulation
i love that hey man that's a great
opening no okay i remember right i
watched because i
i downloaded uh all of back in
monogatari
and all whatever the [ __ ] yeah yeah i
watched them all and i remember i
listened to branagh circulation i
thought wow that's a [ __ ] tune
yeah i went to find it i thought man am
i the only guy who likes this song
i found out like two hours later
literally everyone loves this song yeah
made like the meme compilations
i i'm going to give a hot take though
it's not my favorite morning atari
[ __ ] dances
but like i feel like monogatari has like
so many banger opening
as well even the first opening of
pokemon go yeah yeah staples yeah
that was like a great [ __ ] song
changed the ending every
time i don't know i
yeah because with the monogatari series
it was the first time when i noticed
they were actually
changing the endings like to every arc
and everything
every arc had a different ending i
thought that was like every arc had a
different opening
as well yeah that's true i thought it
was like a really nice touch yeah like
little things like that monogatari polly
yeah i cuz i know there have been other
series that have done that but i can't
think of any off the top of my head
there's a ton i'm sure but
i need to write [ __ ] down i think that's
what i've taken away from this episode
how did the music make me feel i should
write more than one word
i would i wouldn't like a thousand word
essay on how music in anime makes you
[Music]
seeing seeing you process try like try
to process
how music makes you feel it's one of
like the most eye-opening moments i've
ever seen
for you as a friend just like i'm
looking forward to the meme business
i'm ready to get [ __ ] roasted by the
viewers of this yeah
but it's fine i know i i big brain in
some things monkey brain than others
goldfish brain and music yeah combine
this combined with the [ __ ] video
game episode
i'm gonna be like literally everyone's
gonna think i don't like listening to
music i don't want to read
i just want to play chess that's connor
in a nutshell
yeah i guess what the [ __ ] is going on
with my brain man yeah i don't know
it's a weird man yeah is there anything
else you guys want to talk about for
this
episode i don't think so i think we've
covered here are the lovely patrons on
the screen right now thank you very much
to the patrons for helping us support
this shout out to those guys
those are great guys these guys are my
favorite guys
these are my favorite how do those guys
make you feel cool
how do the patrons make you
also if you want to stick around and uh
figure out what we're doing
off youtube and spotify and whatnot then
you can also follow us on twitter
at trashtaspod and we also have a
subreddit where you guys give us plenty
of
dank memes yes we always check the
subreddit we always check the twitter so
uh at this
at the moment of this recording it's
just full of chess memes yeah lots of
chess keeping great
lots of great [ __ ] fan art as well
we're a little ahead at the moment but
that's because we're eventually going to
travel at some point
yeah we need to get a little backlog
going exactly exactly yeah
i'm the boy thank you for watching this
episode of trash taste with the two
other boys they make me feel
happy good and i've been
man thank you very much man
thank you man what's wrong with me man
what's wrong
my mom's gonna think what happened to my
boy
join us next episode where we teach man
how to make fire
literally gonna turn it into what's that
channel called with a like prime
primitive music featuring we're going to
teach him the xylophone
it's going to be our goal just to see
like the evolution of connor as this
podcast goes along
from like from like caveman to like
sophisticated humor here's what's gonna
happen
next time i watch a show i'm gonna make
note of the soundtrack and how it makes
me feel
in more than one line yeah more than one
word
ah yeah we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you